je vous attendais pour continuer
l'histoire de la guerre de cent ans
souvenez-vous nous nous étions arrêtés
au début de cette très longue guerre
quand le roi d'angleterre avait envoyé
ses représentants
ici dans l'île aux enfants pour demander
au roi casimir us de laisser les soldats
anglais envahir l'île aux enfants
alors vous êtes d'accord - pour
concourir mon île c'est cela d'accord
mais à une condition que vous attendiez
quand je sois mort et que la guerre dure
moins de cent ans
nous allons délibérer qu'en pensez vous
là la proposition est intéressante il
est très vieux
il va bientôt mourir et de signer un
traité nous évitera d'avoir à envahir
l'île
parce qu'à mon avis ces lapins sont de
redoutables bombarde
vous allez peut-être réseau et cette
guerre qui doit durer moins de cent ans
c'est ridicule aucune guerre l'a jamais
durant les cent ans salim procès ben
c'est donc tout intérêt à signer cet
accord
je le crois bilan cela nous évitera je
vous le répète d'avoir à envahir lui je
vais donc signé majesté c'est d'accord
très bien alors garde un geste est assis
toi et rédige l'accord
vos ordres voilà bonjour majesté bonjour
mais seigneur je vous présente un joli
d'arc
bonjour gentes demoiselles majesté j'ai
entendu des voix qui m'ont dit qu'il
fallait que je chasse les anglais les
allemands les lentilles 3 39% et de la
généreuse anglais je vais leur passé la
ville à rire mais non enfin je lis à
arak tu vas tout gâcher et puis la
guerre n'est pas une affaire de femmes
très bien si tout le monde est contre
moi s'en retourne à mes moutons monde et
dès lors de ne pas s'en faire pour le
chant de 40 ça s'arrange
les jeunes filles d'aujourd'hui sont de
grands garçons manqués à arras pour sûr
de monter ce n'était d'accord bat est
prêt à l'attendre un petit moulin bien
voilà avoue milan ni le était là voilà
ils ont bravé kazemi rue sera morts
avant un an et moi là je suis jeune
souple et en bonne santé regardez voilà
très bien
vous nous avez bien rude mais nous
reviendrons
vous serez mort bientôt au revoir aux
chirurgies à bientôt
[Rires]
bon alors ouvert planté ce champ de 40
ha ha
je
c'est ainsi que commença pour les
casimir us la guerre de cent ans